et nous savions qu'il l'était car nous avions travaillé avec.
Mais je savais ce qu'il voulait dire,
car ça aurait pu être possible de prendre un tas de photos
de fleurs dans un jardin et ensuite, simplement les indexer
dans un ordinateur de telle sorte qu'on pourrait croire
qu'il y avait un vrai robot alors qu'il n'y en avait pas.
Et plus j'y pensais, moins je voyais
une bonne réponse pour lui montrer comment faire la différence.
C'était juste au moment ou l'on m'a proposé un poste
ici à Berkeley,
et quand je suis arrivé j'ai contacté Hubert Dreyfus,
qui est un professeur de philosophie de renommée mondiale,
et je lui ai parlé de cela, et il m'a dit,
"C'est l'un des problèmes les plus anciens et les plus centraux
en philosophie. Il remonte aux Sceptiques,
et va jusqu'à Descartes.
C'est le sujet de l'épistémologie,
qui étudie la vérité des choses."
Donc nous avons commencé à travailler ensemble,
et nous avons inventé un nouveau terme: télépistémologie,
l'étude de la connaissance à distance.
Nous avons invité de grands artistes et ingénieurs,
ainsi que des philosophes à écrire des articles à ce sujet,
et les résultats ont été rassemblés dans ce livre
des presses du MIT.
Je remercie donc cet étudiant d'avoir questionné
ce que tout le monde supposait vrai,
ce projet m'a appris quelque chose d'important sur la vie,
c'est de toujours questionner les suppositions.
Maintenant le second projet dont je vais vous parler
est venu du Téléjardin.
Pendant qu'il fonctionnait, mes étudiants et moi-même étions interessés
par comment les gens interagissaient les uns avec les autres
et ce qu'ils faisaient du jardin.
Nous avons commencé à imaginer ce qu'il se passerait si le robot pouvait sortir
du jardin et aller dans un autre
environnement intéressant?
Par exemple, pourquoi ne pourrait-il pas aller dans une soirée festive
à la maison Blanche? (Rires)
Donc comme nous étions plus interessés par le design du système
et dans l'interface utilisateur que par le hardware,
nous avons décidé que, plutot que d'avoir
un robot remplaçant l'humain pour aller dans une fête,
nous aurions un humain remplaçant le robot.
Nous l'avons appelé le Télé-Acteur.
Nous prenions un humain,
une personne très extravertie et sociable,
et elle était équipée d'un casque
portant divers équipements, caméras et micros,
ainsi que d'un sac à dos avec une connection internet sans-fil,
et l'idée était qu'elle pouvait aller dans un endroit lointain et
passionnant, et ensuite sur Internet,
les gens pourraient faire l'expérience de ce qu'elle vivait,
donc ils pourraient voir ce qu'elle voyait,
mais surtout, en plus, ils pourraient participer
en interagissant les uns avec les autres
et arriver à trouver des idées sur ce qu'elle devrait faire ensuite
et où elle devrait aller,
et ensuite transmettre cela au Télé-acteur.
On a eu la chance de présenter le Télé-acteur
au Webby Awards de San Francisco,
et cette année-là, Sam Donaldson était l'hôte.
Juste avant que le rideau ne se lève, j'ai eu 30 secondes
pour expliquer à M. Donaldson ce que nous allions faire,
et j'ai dit: " Le Télé-Acteur
va nous rejoindre sur scène,
c'est un nouveau projet expérimental,
et les gens la regardent sur leurs écrans,
et elle a -- il y a des caméras sur elle
et des microphones et elle a une oreillette,
et les gens sur le réseau lui donne des conseils
sur quoi faire."
Et il a dit, "Attendez une seconde,
C'est ce que moi je fais." (Rires)
Donc il a adoré le concept,
et quand le Télé-acteur est arrivé sur scène,
elle a avancé vers lui, et elle l'a embrassé
en plein sur la bouche. (Rires)
Nous étions complètement ébahis
car nous n'avions aucune idée de ce qui allait arriver.
Et il a été génial. Il lui a donné une grande accolade en retour,
et tout s'est bien passé.
Mais cette nuit là, alors que nous étions en train de ranger,
j'ai demandé au Télé-Acteur comment les Télé-Directeurs
avaient décidé qu'elle embrasserait Sam Donaldson.
Et elle m'a dit qu'ils ne l'avaient pas fait.
Elle a dit que quand elle était sur le point de monter sur scène,
les Télé-Directeurs étaient toujours en train d'essayer de décider quoi faire,
et donc elle est juste montée sur scène et a fait
ce qu elle sentait être le plus naturel. (Rires)
Donc, le succès du Télé-Acteur cette nuit-là
était dû au fait qu'elle était une merveilleuse actrice.
Elle savait quand faire confiance à son instinct,
et ce projet m'a donc donné une autre leçon de vie -
quand on est dans le doute, il faut improviser. (Rires)
Maintenant le 3ème projet est venu
de mon expérience du temps où mon père était à l'hôpital.
Il suivait un traitement,
de la chimiothérapie, et un traitement associé
appelé brachythérapie, ou de minuscules particules radioactives
sont placées dans le corps pour traiter les tumeurs cancéreuses.
Et la manière dont c'est fait, comme vous pouvez le voir ici,
le chirurgien plante des aiguilles dans le corps
pour injecter les particules, et tout cela,
toutes ces aiguilles sont insérées en parallèle,
donc il est très courant que certaines des aiguilles
traversent des organes sensibles, ainsi,
ces aiguilles abîment ces organes, et produisent des dégâts
qui engendrent des traumatismes et des effets secondaires.
Donc avec mes étudiants je me suis demandé, et si nous pouvions
modifier ce système
pour que les aiguilles puissent venir avec des angles différents?
Donc nous avons simulé cela et developpé certains
algorithmes d'optimisation et nous avons simulé cela,
et avons été capables de montrer que l'on peut éviter
les organes fragiles tout en maintenant une couverture
efficace de la tumeur avec les radiations.
Donc maintenant nous travaillons avec des docteurs d'UCSF
et des ingénieurs de Johns Hopkins
et nous construisons un robot,
spécialement concu avec plusieurs articulations qui permettent
aux aiguilles de pénétrer avec une infinité d'angles possibles,
et comme vous pouvez le voir, elles peuvent éviter les organes fragiles
et quand même atteindre leurs cibles.
Donc en remettant en cause l'hypothèse que toutes les aiguilles
doivent arriver de manière parallèle, ce projet m'a aussi appris
une leçon importante: Quand on est dans le doute,
quand votre chemin est bloqué, pivotez !
Et le dernier projet est aussi en lien avec la robotique médicale
et c'est quelque chose qui est venu d'un système appelé
le robot chirurgien "da Vinci" ,
et c'est un système qui est disponible dans le commerce.
Il est utilisé dans plus de 2 000 hopitaux dans le monde,
et l'idée est qu'il permet au chirugien
d'opérer confortablement dans son propre système de coordonnées,
car beaucoup de petites tâches chirurgicales
sont très routinières et fastidieuses, comme recoudre une plaie,
et en ce moment, tout cela est réalisé
spécifiquement et directement par le chirurgien,
ce qui fait que le chirurgien se fatigue avec le temps.
On s'est donc demandé
si nous pouvions programmer le robot
pour qu'il réalise certaines de ces tâches,
et ainsi libérer les chirurgiens qui pourraient se concentrer
sur les parties les plus compliquées de la chirurgie,
et aussi réduire le temps nécessaire à l'opération
si nous pouvions faire que le robot réalise ces tâches un peu plus vite?
En fait, c'est très dur de programmer un robot pour des tâches de précision
comme celles-ci, mais il se trouve que mon collègue, Pieter Abbeel,
qui est à Berkeley, a developpé
une série de nouvelles techniques pour apprendre aux robots à partir d'un exemple.
Donc il a réussi à ce que des robots pilotent un hélicoptère,
fassent des choses incroyablement intéressantes, de belles acrobaties,
en leur montrant des experts humains les pilotant.
Donc nous avons pris l'un de ses robots.
Nous avons commencé à travailler avec Pieter et ses étudiants,
et nous avons demandé à un chirurgien d'accomplir
une tâche, et ce qu'on fait avec le robot,
donc ce qu'on fait c'est demander au robot,
au chirurgien d'exécuter la tâche,
et on enregistre les mouvements du robot.
Voila un exemple. Je vais utiliser la figure du huit,
le fait de tracer la figure huit comme un exemple.
Donc voila à quoi ça ressemble quand le robot,
voilà ce à quoi la trajectoire du robot ressemble
dans ces trois exemples.
C'est en fait bien meilleur que ce qu'un débutant
comme moi pourrait faire, mais c'est quand même saccadé et imprécis.
Donc nous enregistrons tous ces exemples, comme données,
et puis nous procédons par étapes.
D'abord nous utilisons une technique appelée déformation dynamique du temps
venant de la reconnaissance de discours, et cela nous permet
d'aligner tous les exemples dans le même temps
et ensuite nous appliquons un filtrage de Kalman
une technique de la théorie de la régulation, qui nous permet
d'analyser le bruit statistique
et d'extraire la trajectoire désirée sous-jacente.
Donc ce que l'on fait c'est qu'on prend
ces démonstrations humaines, qui sont toutes bruitées et imparfaites,
et nous en extrayons une trajectoire de tâche
et une séquence de contrôle pour le robot.
Ensuite on fait marcher le robot avec cette séquence,
et on observe le résultat,
puis on adjuste les contrôles avec une séquence de techniques
appelée apprentissage itératif.
Puis on augmente un peu la vitesse du robot.
On observe les résultats et on ré-ajuste les contrôles de nouveau,
et on regarde ce qui se passe.
Et l'on répète cela plusieurs fois.
Et voilà le résultat.
C'est la trajectoire déduite,
et voilà le robot bougeant à la vitesse d'un humain.
Ici, il va quatre fois plus vite qu'un humain.
Ici sept fois.
Et là le robot fait l'opération 10 fois
plus vite qu'un humain.
Donc, on est capable d'avoir un robot qui accomplit des tâches précises,
comme une tâche chirurgicale,
10 fois plus vite qu'un humain.
Donc ce projet aussi, parce qu'il impliquait de la pratique
et de l'apprentissage, en faisant quelque chose encore et encore,
ce projet aussi m'a appris que,
si vous voulez bien faire quelque chose,
il n'y a rien qui remplace l'entraînement , l'entraînement, et encore l'entraînement .
Ce sont donc les 4 leçons que j'ai apprises
grâce aux robots au fil des ans,
et la robotique, le champ de la robotique s'est beaucoup amélioré
avec le temps.
De nos jours, des lycéens peuvent construire des robots
comme le robot industriel que mon père et moi avons essayé de construire.
Et maintenant j'ai une fille,
qui s'appelle Odessa.
Elle a huit ans,
et elle aime les robots aussi.
Peut-être que c'est dans le sang. (Rires)
J'aurai voulu qu'elle puisse rencontrer mon père.
Et maintenant c'est moi qui dois lui apprendre comment les choses marchent,
et nous pouvons construire des projets ensemble, et je me demande
quel genre de choses cela lui apprendra.
Les robots sont les plus humaines
de nos machines.
Ils ne peuvent pas résoudre tous les problèmes du monde,
mais je pense qu'ils ont des choses importantes à nous apprendre.
J'invite tous ceux qui pensent à des innovations
qui les intéressent,
aux machines dont vous rêvez,
et pensez à ce qu'elles pourraient vous enseigner,
parce que j'ai le préssentiment
que beaucoup de nos innovations technologiques,
des objets dont nous rêvons,
peuvent nous inspirer à devenir meilleurs.
Merci. (Applaudissements)